diamond simon simon's on my neck on my
wrist
diamonds diamonds diamonds on my fist
yeah
amanda bynes is showing off her musical
side
the actor shares a surprise sneak peek
to instagram the rap song is a
collaboration with her fiance paul
michael the couple got engaged on
valentine's day last year let's hear a
little more from this track diamonds
diamonds diamonds on my neck on my wrist
and the unexpected drop has been in the
works for a minute in a statement on
wednesday amanda's attorney tells et
amanda is creative and playful she had a
lot of fun recording diamonds during the
first shutdown of the pandemic she is
now able to share it with her fans
the new song comes soon after an
important life update in march amanda
was released from her conservatorship
after nearly a decade following the news
amanda's attorney told et the former
child star was excited and looking
forward to living life as a private and
normal citizen amanda shared this update
leading up to the court ruling what's up
instagram amanda bynes here
my court date is coming up in two weeks
i want to thank you all so much for your
love and support peace out the
conservatorship was first put into place
when amanda was 27 after she had several
run-ins with police and was placed under
an involuntary psychiatric hole but now
amanda is focusing on school and a
future business career while also diving
into her creative pursuits just last
month she told et in a statement i'm
continuing with my bachelor's degree at
fidm majoring in creative industry
studies meanwhile a source also tells
e.t amanda is very happy and has been
enjoying her freedom
[Music]